hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
the complexities of sv analytical
ultracentrifugation
aavs are not simple binary systems
my name is akash bhutacharya and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by beckham counter life
sciences
the views expressed in this webinar are
those of the speaker
and not of beckman culture life sciences
for more information on beckman cultural
solutions
please visit www.beckman.com
before we get started we'd like to get
to know our audience with a couple of
questions
so here's the first question is
analytical ultracentrifugation or auc
currently a part of your analytical
workflows
option a for yes and option b
for no this question should appear
on your screen right now
the second audience poll question is
are good manufacturing practices or gmp
important to your analytical workflow
needs
option a for very important option b
for somewhat important option c for not
very important option d not important at
all
and option e for i am not sure
and the third and final audience poll
question is
your work environment is best described
as
option a for r d or discovery
option b for process development
option c for manufacturing
an option d for quality control
or analytical development or
characterization
now that we've taken a moment to answer
these questions
i'd like to thank you all for your
answers
with that i would also like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question
box and click on the send button also
please notice that you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
if you're having trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the supports tab found at the
top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our speaker dr
lake paul
founder and president of bioanalysis llc
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr paul you may now begin your
presentation
thank you akash for the introduction
today i want to talk about
the complexities of a you see
specifically in relation to the
genotherapy
field the gene therapy field has really
exploded over the last few years well
it has been previously but now it's
become one of the
forefront frontiers of
uh revolutionary and transformative
medicine
in um in our modern history and
auc is playing a critical role
in these types of uh of therapy
so what i want to talk about today is
some of the
the characterization and some of the
information that you can gather
from using sedimentation velocity
analytical authentication
and apply it to your gene therapy field
now please note that this is not
limited to only aavs
but can be applied to your lentiviral
systems
or your you know modified synthetic
systems
so it is a very versatile type of
application
and given that the fda the emea
are now recognizing that auc is one of
the
critical components of this type of
analyses
it's paramount that we really focus
on what kind of relative information we
can get
so before i start um going into the
nitty-gritty details of
what analytical authentication can do
for the adv
systems i'd like to give a little
history of what
um we see in um over the years
of um utilizing auc and where where it
began
and then where it is now in the present
day
so what we see here on the screen on the
left hand side is the original
centrifuge that theodor sedberg
developed in
28 26 1926
that of salah and in wisconsin this is
the
the first um centrifuge and it took a
very large very complicated instrument
but with this he won the nobel prize
to looking at global gold colloidal
systems
and then characterizing the molecular
weights
as time went by you know the centrifuge
became smaller in this case um
we had the sprinkle uh modli systems
which was basically a room um
the size of a room so this actually
helped
um modernize the centrifuge but what
happened
is that the centrifuge became very
specialized
and it took a special operator to really
divulge and get the information from the
uh
from the the data in addition to that
with the advances of you know what we
consider at that time what we consider
modern technology your sds page
sizing columns um it became um
very um not very intuitive
to use a complicated system to get the
molecular weights or distributions
when you can use a simpler system like a
sps page or a scc column to get the
molecular weight so
through that time it fell out of grace
and there was not a lot of development
um
put into the the centrifuge at this time
it is called
this is during the 70s so what happened
is a whole generation of scientists
did not get did not learn about the
centrifuge
however in um around the
early 90s to late 90s some of the
pioneers of the centrifuge field
tom lowway philo jafantas
shockman continued to push for
better technologies and in this case
beckman responded by
producing the xla and xli
and these instruments um during their
late 90s um early 90s
really put the the centrifuge to the
forefront
and it came
from the software um with boris
delimitary software
filo software and shook software that
made it easy
make these complex calculations complex
fitting data analysis more accessible to
the masses and with that it really
blossomed the field recently
beckman has pushed out the new optima
auc which improves upon
the technologies that we have seen in
the um
with xla and xli and you know improved
scanning frequency
uh better optical systems
faster collection rates you know better
cooling systems
once it's fixed and so forth and so it
is pushing the boundaries again with the
optima auc
and with that and with these modern
softwares you can really now
apply the the theory
um and the the the versatility of the
auc
to a wide variety of systems now asd is
not
limited just to biologics it's being
used
very very much in the nanoparticle field
and the polymer field
and you know it it is just a very
versatile instrument and it is the gold
standard
in measuring measuring side
distributions molecular weights
here and self-associations
so one of the things i want to talk
about is that
all of the the the experiments that you
do
with auc are basing first principles
that means there's no modification of
your system
you pipe it in your uh your uh
your sample into the the the two sector
into the sector
the sample sector pipeline and pipe it
in your your buffer
into the reference sector and you apply
the centrifugal force
from that you watch the boundaries move
that's it
very simple experimental setup without
any need for immobilization labeling
modification of your of your of your
system
but with that comes a great weight
on the secondary analyses that goes
into it there's always the same garbage
in
garbage out so you have to be very
careful in your sample preparation
to get the most highly
pure name pure but highly good
sample really good sample to put in and
that's not a limitation but it's
you know effort has to be made made up
front
to really know what your buffer
constituents are
and how your sample behaves so
with this you know there are several
different approaches on the
on the uh analysis of the of the data
now what we when we look at
sedimentation uh boundaries all we see
is a
you know the curvature of your solvent
the plateau region and your reaction
boundaries if you have a
hetero or self-associating systems and
we have to fit
the lamb equation the separate equation
is the derivative of that
and it is a model fitted that you're
looking at you're
you're not looking at a direct
data output as per say if you're looking
at a mass spectrometry data
in which you have the masses and you can
figure out the differences between the
uh
the masses to figure out your uh your
amino acid
acid composition this is a
model fitted type of analysis so the
hardest part in these type of analysis
is realizing which is real which peaks
are real and which
which which ones are not and you have to
do
multiple approaches to really know
what is real and what is not real and
this is the major
complaint of everyone else who uh
is doing alternative methods to look at
for example your mp4 ratio
so for example if you're doing sick
malls um
the their claim um it's very easy to do
that's the first thing they say
it's very easy to do but there's
information being
missed if you use cdmes
very easy to do well right now it's
pretty difficult but it's um
that technology's gone improving but
their information
can be known you have to deconvolute a
very um a charge envelope to get your
data
um in in terms of the new cesds
i mean there's a lot of reproducibility
problems but you know you have
to do a lot of sample prep at that point
in time now the biggest complaint going
back to that
my original uh proposal the biggest
complaint
is you re it requires an expert to do it
yes this is true but to get to the level
of expert just requires training
and education educating the masses on
how to do this is an
easier task than trying to reinvent the
wheel
and auc is the gold standard
check miles cdm cdnes um
cd ms um uh
cesds all go back to
auc for uh for um for confirmation
even your em and tm data requires a save
however you have to when you're doing
your um
data analysis you have to be very
careful in how you model
model it so in this case there's
multiple people have developed
strategies on how to do this type of
fitting of the data in which you go from
regularization to least
minimization and different outputs of
your data
one of the biggest things i had to tell
everyone your
cfs distribution your gfs distribution
is not a chromatograph please
think of it as it looks like a
chromatogram but it is
not it is a fit of the data
and this is a very very key and
important point
so one of the some of the softwares that
have come along
the dc-dtp plus by you know filo set it
now
by stafford ultra japan by boris
saturday the setback by
uh peter shook these programs are
wonderful
each has its strengths and each has his
weaknesses
i implore people to try all and see
which one
um best fits your system or as
in my case i'm very agnostic i use them
all to get to the right data
um the right conclusion so
what um with these modern software it's
very easy
um to to figure out what is in your
system
from a first approach so what we want to
look at um
next is the history of auc and viruses
now shopman did this in 1949 1950
and he thought he did a great study on
the tobacco
mosaic virus the techniques
and mythology has has already been
established all you have to do is go and
read
and and from those read it of those
wonderful papers and wonderful book
chapters and books
that um shockman has written uh
jack uh stafford stephen harding off the
road all of these guys have
developed the methods already all you
have to do is go back and read
and apply now one of the things that
we're looking at here is uh
basically this on your the blue figure
right there is your tobacco mosaic virus
the middle figure there is your brown
mosaic virus and that's an av
on your right hand side surely optics
was used in this case
one of the coolest things about this is
that june in 1951
was the first evidence of cell
sharpening which is a common
problem in large particles um
especially when looking at the avs it
can be a problem
and there's some things you have to
really think about it
in this case so this is you have all the
information
already in uh at your graph it just
requires a little reading or
um come talk to one of myself or
any other experts you can find in the
area and we can direct you or we can
help you with these kind of situations
now let's go right into the gene therapy
area and look at the
cqas for the system now traditionally
we are looking at percent empty percent
full
now we can take that and expand upon
that
and look at your percent intermediate
slash partials
look at your lower order capsids which
is anything
lower than your smaller or lower in
s value range than your empty capsid or
your higher order capsid which is
anything
greater than your full capsid in this
case could be aggregates
and you can expand upon that but right
now
the fda um the emea are focused on the
np capsid but
i can tell you this is going to change
they will
they are seeing the power of auc and
it can do much more than that
so when you're looking at these systems
you have to think about
either character whether the first step
is characterization
and then the cqa at that point in time
you establish what your cqa
needs to be and you use the auc to help
that question
now you can look at the imperative
impurity and flash
purity profile you can detect um
small um proteins in there rep 68
is one of them there's a paper that's
coming out that looks at
the organization state
of rep 68 which helps with protein
integration
if your purification system is is um
troublesome you can see this protein in
there
yes you can and you can see the aoc
quantify it and it's it's it you can
you can really assess your impurity
profile
um if you're clever um using some clever
tricks you can figure out the dna
loading
of the uh the viral particles um you can
look at your ratios for your process of
manufacturing consistencies
and i mentioned um high order capsids
extinction coefficients um tom lowey and
a lot of other authors use auc to
determine the extinction coefficients
uh of your protein you don't have to do
a amino acid hydrolysis to figure this
out
you can do it with if um using the
multi-signal
type of system um
the second la the last three uh points
in there are mainly
uh for mass spectrometer we're not going
to go into that um
but overall you can look at your cqa of
your system
especially when it comes to auc um
to look at your empty capsid partial
capacitive full capsid's
contaminant profile and so forth
now tem is a good technique
but it has its limitations um prior um
is the technique
but it has the limitations same with set
molds
has limitations and you have to know
what limitations you want to do to live
with it
um so what i wanted to go for um go into
is basically some of the i'm going to
touch bases on some of the multi-signal
approaches
now on your left-hand side is some
boundaries uh
both from a um interference optic system
and a um absorber software system and
you can explore the intel
uh the intrinsic properties of your um
of your system because bear's law is
additive
if you know your dna extension
corresponds to your dna you can
uh i know your physical efficiency you
can figure that out
the same properties are for your
interference optics which is based off
of your
um your dndc a refractive index so your
dna is about 0.17 and your proteins
about 0.188
and you can estimate your package system
in there
you can confirm your
your contaminant if it has dna in it you
can look at the signal differences
you can um look at your aggregates to
figure out whether it is
a dimer of your your your pro of your
of your of your full capsids or your
empty cancers and so forth you
can figure all of this out in a single
run
okay you just you can you can do this
once you have properly designed the
experiment
um and then there's a lot more
information you can do with the
multi-signal
now you can globally fit this data or
you can
fit it individually both approaches can
work
and it requires a little more time but
it can be done and once it's done you
have a
great package to put into your ind your
blair
mma um what i want to talk about next
we all know this about your empty
parchment full
um the the lod actually i have to change
his led because you can get
led sub 1
sub 1 think about that for a second that
is looking at a
very magnet amount of um
anti-capsules or acids in this case
and you can get llqs that is sub
um two percent at times um so
you have to be very careful in how you
design these experiments
to get these type of low
lods and low loqs now your intel
intro reproducibility one to one
by one to one point five percent
standard deviations
and this was you know performed by um um
um a colleague of mine richard hearn in
which she looked at this um type of uh
intra and interested um reproducibility
and found this out
personally i found this you can have
very very low standard deviation
especially when it comes to your
sedimentation coefficients
i mean you can have plus or minus 0.2
um s values shipped you're
it's very very robust in this type of um
environment and this is what you need to
develop a really good
method and as i said before i mentioned
it's compatible with many systems
and it's done in your native matrices
so there's no need for labeling
staining or immobilization it is a
wonderful system
in in in terms of that um
when we go into experimental design this
is a
very very critical um
portion of your um of your
of your system in which you have to
spend the most time in
now your selection of growth of speed
you spin too fast
you can have some problems
self-sharpening you can have
non-ideality
you can have a lot of problems you can
you
would with too fast over a road to speed
but there
you know you still get data what is the
best data
sometimes not sometimes it can be with
um
with slower road to speed just remember
you get a better handle on your
diffusion if you spin
it slower because the boundaries are um
separate our diffusion limit is the
square root of
the average of d times your time um
so too fast you have done reality you
can have
sometimes you can have better resolution
but that can create more problems in
your data fitted
okay and that's something of walking of
species which are very close together
or close to a a very abundant uh species
in your system
if you to run too slow you have a long
experimental time so that's a lower
throughput
lower resolution but it's a delicate
balance between that
and as i said before you get a better
handle on your diffusion
your acid concentrations very very
important the linearity of your optical
system
is about 0.1 to 1.0
and sometimes you can put it up to 1.2
depending on your system
um anywhere in between that i recommend
you do
anything above 0.5 to get the best
idea however remember you don't
have to be at 0.5 od units to get the
best data
you can get data from 0.01
it's going to have a lot of noise but
there's some things in there you can
figure out
you can get good data 0.1 od units at 2
30.
it is still good data okay
so no one should tell you that you have
to put the assay
at 0.5 absolutely incorrect
it's a it's a you can anyway any
any tense in that 0.1 to 1.2 1.0 range
will give you good data um
however the lower the concentrations
that you get
you get the broadening of the peaks this
is a function of zebfit
and regularization um it becomes a
little problematic
in your system now the different
approaches to this
um to figure out whether your peaks are
or real or
um where centered at so
you know you have to really be careful
with with how you're doing your acid
concentrations
just remember if you're doing an assay
in which you're looking at
say three percent of your
empties in there you're not going to use
a very low concentration
to get that because that at that point
in time your overall signal
for your um your anticapsid or partial
capsids is going to be three percent of
the total
okay so you want to have enough um
signal in there that is differentiatable
from your noise to give you the best
type of result
so you have to be very careful in your
assay concentrations
one of the things that you're going to
have is the ripple effect
because of regularization and how it
works and that's going out to the
higher s values so
in reality this is simulated data this
is what we expect
i mean nice peaks at you know around 65
for empty depends on your size of your
insert in this case
maybe of your weighted average so your
full capsule peak
your fc is around 101
but in reality that's what you get in
the blue line
a smear at times and it's not that easy
to
um figure out your positioning of your
uh
um your empty capsid what is
intermediate
your full capsule if you have a really
good system um that peak will be nice
and sharp
but once you start getting you know your
your yourself defeated at every point in
time
in which you are trying to reduce the
empty impartial which in turns make the
analysis
more difficult to do because you have a
lower concentration
at this point in time and you can have
merging of peaks
so that's some of the things that you
have to take into consideration
when you're going um doing your assays
but there's a worker on to this so
if we look at the analytical landscape
so let's look at the little funnel on
the side there
this is how i approach my
mythology to do the um to generate your
final distribution
now the fda the emea and all these
regulatory agencies have
are have seen the cfs distribution
we will look at that as the the final
output but how do you get to that final
cfs distribution
to make sure that it is absolutely
correct
and that's the thing you have to not
rely you if you rely too much on one
analysis you're going to go on a very
very bad path
and i i i'm off the mind or program
analysis
or terminal methods that's our
alternative
data fitted is the key so at this point
in time you have to do some of your um
orthogonal modeling
and this is a lsg star s a g g star
s analysis or even a hybrid continuous
local discrete
global uh analysis this isn't said
that's a little more complicated
so you can look at these type of
distributions
so the first thing we're going to look
at the first input you get
is your cfs distribution and it's going
to be your last
you're going to use that for your
distribution model and that is where you
start at
now your rmsb a lot of folks rely on the
rmsd
this can be misleading um at some points
if you load enough data into the setfit
you're going to artificially lower your
rmsd okay
that what you have to do is a
comparative analysis
looking at the global chi-square changes
of your um rmsd between
fit one and fit two and this goes is it
a rated process
to figure out whether you are stuck in a
local
or a global minimum and you have to be
able to
do this type of analysis looking at your
global pi square
looking at your um confidence intervals
that you have
looking at the the the landscape this um
the surface error projections of your
data this is all
built into the set that um said fit and
said fat and
um your um ultra scanner and so forth
you have to look at these data um
certain programs do rely on
rmsd which is but that's a different
type of analysis and a different
approach
to the um solution to the um severe
equation
so you have to be very careful on what
what your rmsd really means
look at your boundaries look at your
systematic
errors look for systematicity and so
forth
your fitting parameters have to be
optimized you have to know
what your ti and ri noise are doing
in your systems ultrascan likes both ti
and ri
in said fit the application has to be
very systematic
for example the ri noise was it
originally done for
interference data while you're applying
it to your
absorbance data as philo would say if
your data your data should be good
enough
coming out of the centrifuge to require
no noise
um correction yes and no
the ti node is yes the ri noise probably
not
so you have to be very careful in that
the amount of regularization this is a
very critical point people are
very um keen to do it at 0.95
but you have to know what the
regularization is doing
and how to apply this type of um
confidence to your data so
when you're looking at your maximum
entropy or your second derivative
type of analyses they have to
be able to align um they have to tell
you the same thing
at the same time there's also the
bayesian implementation
um that is instead said fit that not a
lot of people use
but it can be done very effectively to
look at
capsid heterogeneity
your cs model does it make sense
identification of your artificial peaks
how to get out of a local minimum there
are steps to do this
your data remember that the error
service is very very complicated and
filled with local minima before you can
get to your
your global minimum so you have to learn
how to
do an iterative approach to get to the
best solution of your data and those are
some of the things you
you you will learn over time how to do
this
iterative approaches to this changing
the values that you're fit into
non-optimal and see where
it converges back looking at your your
chi-squared um changes i'm looking at um
your um the histogram plot that you we
have now
in um implemented in in in said kit
um you can look at these type of things
and figure out what what makes the sense
now the most critical part of this is
identification of peaks that
are real and not real everything in
there
based off the the function of
regularization it is saying
that every sedimentation coefficient is
possible so hope you have to
keep that in mind that everything is
possible so when you're looking at your
derivatives
your solution is this the true solution
okay and there are different ways to
approach that
so let's this is a good a good um
example
of what we're seeing here so of the
power of these programs that you have
so if you look at this data here i mean
it's it's not
um one of those um you know
uh means in which you look and you're
finally gonna see a blue dress or
a green dress or something like that
this is random noise
however when you apply said fit
this is a beautiful fit i mean if you
look at that
um the gray panel in there there's no
har on diagonal lines that shows that
indicates no system assisting the era
the residuals are very um very nice
no systematic area in there but the
solution is wrong
it is wrong it is
basically fitting noise to something and
that's the power of these uh
regularization that you have um what the
if of all the marvel folks out there
um if you like spider-man with great
power comes great
responsibility this is what we're trying
to
implement here is you have to be very
careful in your solutions
so be careful and on on how
what date what data you're looking at
and how it's been
processed so let's continue on
you have to know the limitations um so
one of the things of maximum entropy is
a tendency to merge
two very close peaks so once the
concentrations are very low
it starts to pull those in it it is
designed initially to give the sharpest
peak
but at low concentrations you start to
see
merging sometimes you pose
concentrations from larger peaks
implemented there
so that is some of the things that we
have to um
to think about in addition it's over
large distributions you have
um oscillations so you have to be very
careful so
what i want to look at here you have
your ideal versus expected
and what we need to do is look at the um
what we're going to do is to discrete uh
a kind of a iterative approach
look at discrete models um of the data
so in this case i
simulate the data i knew what was in
there so i fit four models to
these discrete species so telling me
that this this solution has at least
four species in there
that can describe this data in addition
to that i do
lsg star or g-star s it doesn't have the
resolution but it gives you good
quantitative values
and shows that um if your profile is
looking relatively same
you can you know make a good decision on
this
in addition to that um what you can look
at
is your um your
basically you're trying to refine your
fit
so what i did i took that blue
um reality data and refined
that same data to give me discrete
species and this is very critical when
it comes to translating the auc
into the cgmp environment as a release
test
it is your peaks that has to be
discernible from each other
for for proper integration and that is
one of the major
issues that i see a lot if these peaks
are emerging because of improper fits
and you can really tease these out
independent
implement a robust method that will do
all of this type of uh analysis and give
you good
a good method that is really
robust in the gmp world so
let's go go back so this is basically
what we were looking at for process
development
and um and characterization
of your system these the size of these
balls are
critical because you take a larger time
in this in this
in this area to give you your final
distribution so once you have this
it is a little bit easier to go into the
gmp so
do the work up front so what you're
looking at a gmp method it has to be
robust
it has to be um reproducible it has to
be able to measure another
response regions very um very
repetitively and in a good order so it
does take a little more time
in your experimental design to
get that and then your signal to noise
evaluation
not so much of your orthogonal modeling
but
you have to confirm your data and i've
developed methods in which
they can you control a kitchen second
and it will pass
it will pick up what it needs to pick up
and it um
it will respond the way it responds
without any type of
unwanted or fitted 4s's and so forth
well anyways this brings me to the end
of my talk and
um thank you so much and thank you for
having me
okay thank you dr paul for this
extremely
informative presentation so
for the audience while we give
dr paul a couple of moments to catch his
breath
maybe get a sip of water before we go
into the main q a portion
we would like to know if auc is a future
consideration
for your laboratory please select from
one of the options
a not applicable i'm already using auc
option b yes and i would like to speak
to a specialist
option c maybe but i'm unsure whether
it's a fit for my samples
option d i'm not sure i need more
information
and option e for no i do not foresee
a future need based upon your responses
to these questions beckman culture life
sciences
will get in touch with you for further
discussions
thank you for your selections we will
now start
the live q a portion of this webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
and with that let's get started
our first question
of the day is
as follows
what are the key factors that i should
consider
helping me decide if i should bring auc
in house
versus sending out to a cro
lake so
this is a good question and um thank you
um akash
um so the first thing for a you see
in-house
uh is that you can you have control over
you know your methods and so forth um
send out the cro i'm i'm biased because
i am a cro so you always want to have
that expertise
the the the high the major critical the
creator the
critical point in bringing an auc
in-house
is having an expert that really knows
what they're doing with auc and i mean
by
expert is someone who has
looked at different systems not only
maps
not only viral systems but has really
explored the space and
of auc in terms of experimental design
because the applications of auc in maps
it's not it's somewhat kind of available
to
avs but it's not the same so
bringing it in-house it can be in
initial start-up costs are going to be a
little bit high
um but in the long run you can
you have the flexibility of having
in-house now the choice of using
a cro depends on the competency
and that is something that you have to
really be
critical about is what type of data are
you looking for
from the cro if you're looking for
running the mail
data there um basically you give your
cfs and that's it
and your cross for that if you want more
in-depth analyses
that gives you both the percent
empties percent full um and gives you
other characterization than their crows
and mine that can give you that but at
the end of the day
um it's it's a it's a choice i the
expertise
out there in crows are is there for your
um
auc just have to make the better choice
coming in house is also beneficial
because you have more control over it
but if you're required to find someone
that is
really knowledgeable um in the auc
system
to really gain the maximum benefit of
that
thank you like so from that business
decision oriented question
to a question which is more on the
regulatory side of things
so here's what the question is what is
the position of the fda
or any other regulatory agency
regarding the use of auc in for example
quality control batch or lot release
testing for viral factors
is it required is it encouraged any
comments
okay so this i've kind of touched upon
this a little bit in my talk
um it is encourage slash required
because the agencies have seen auc
as release tests it has seen
these um this this this technique
as a critical component of controlling
well
monitoring your empty capsids or your
partial capsids
and characterizing your system
so yes it is um i don't i can't speak
and say if it's required
but i know the agencies have seen this
on multiple occasions so encourage
highly recommend
um i would say um but again i'm not
speaking another fda or
emea person but from my experience
um it is um it is one of the techniques
they have seen
most frequently um and it is
used i have seen it used both as a
initial characterization
and as the q series release test it is
moving
more towards the qc release um now
and it's recommended that you develop
methods with the auc
because you're still going to get the
most information
from the auc um from any other technique
set malls tm crown um all of that is not
either cannot be gm gmp
compliant or doesn't provide the
information so
auc is pretty much the golden standard
for this right now thank you lake so
moving forward i think we have several
questions now
which are more on the technical side of
things
and i think they are all connected to
topics which you have spoken about in
your talk
so here's the first one of the technical
questions in the context of c of s
analysis what are the float limits
of the f by f 0 parameter
when it comes to aav analysis
okay so this is this is a very important
question because um
it's it's very it's related to your
molecular weight determination and so
forth so the first thing let's take a
look at the f of x here this is your
shape factor comes from your stokes
einstein relation
relationship in this case in
you have to know how it's implemented in
set fit before you can
really understand what's going on with
this with this value
so the first thing in the um
the shape instead of it this value is
average across your your s min
and your s max in separate so the ranges
that you choose
that f of f zero is averaged okay so it
takes
all the considerations of all the
species and things
hey we're going to use an average shape
to describe
all of this all of these species in here
this is how
the implementation of the apple web zero
is done
in set fit unlike
um said fit ultrascan um
you can put a individual set of
uh uh fos0 for each species
in there um you can do that now setfit
does have that function
i mean which you can assign ranges for
your f10 to describe
um for example you have about modality
or something like that
you can assign a bimodal for f-zero to
one section of the um of the s ranges
and apply another one another web zero
to another section
however we have to be very careful with
the fos0
um you should float it because the
critical parameters
in your your system now
a lot of people will say well your
particles are spherical
okay so that's about 1.2 to 1.3
mainly 1.3 is a perfect sphere um
and we could we can just fix that but
you are
you're you're bypassing what says it
is kind of doing it needs that value to
to really
come to a conclusion well not come to a
conclusion but it's some a critical
component in the solution to the alarm
equation
to get the best you know fit so you want
to be able to you know escape your local
minima and so forth
and go into a local a global minimum so
what i i recommend
is you always float that value i start
with a value of 1.3
and it usually settles around that
between 1.3 to 1.2
now if you start and this is average
across the species now
what that does once it's average it kind
of messes up your molecular weights
so your molecular weights at this point
in time it can be a little bit
off but your molecular weights are not
only dependent on you for f-zero
it's dependent on your v-bar um and your
general rule is if you have
one percent error in your v-bar it's
about
three percent area molecular weight it
also um
your viscosity also affects your
molecular weight
now i do not use a cfs distribution with
a multiple
system multiple species in there and
report the molecular weights because
it becomes nonsensical at that point now
if you have a
very good monolith mono dispersed system
your effort0 can give you
good estimation of your uh molecular
weight
and that's when it is really applied but
you look at you look at the f of
zero for warning signs
of what is going on in your system for
example if you have a
very high um a high amount of
unsedimented species
that is you did not deplete your
meniscus
um you can have the effort of zero can
go high
i mean you can shoot your roof if it
goes if you have dna in there and you're
looking at
something um that is non-spherical then
your f of 0 is going to
approach you know above 1.5 to 2.0 and
that will give you some idea
that hey your system is probably
elongated or something is it's not
perfect
it deviates from a perfect sphere or
something like that so
i usually put it between um i look for a
good fit
between 1.3 1.2 i mean you could get a
1.4
but you know usually it stays with the
viral
system between 1.3 to 1.2
thank you like so during your talk you
mentioned different models so in that
context here is the next question
can you comment of the relative
advantages and disadvantages
of some of the following models
and the models mentioned are bcdt or
time derivative
l s g star of s the
very popular c of s and ultra scans
2d spectrum analysis okay
so um the dc dt and lsg star
s are related they're just two different
approaches
to the um the fujita approximation
um the lsg star is instead fit in the dc
dt is uh
in john pyle's john firo's program
now the noise the convolution is
different in between
um dc dt and lsg star in the terms of
bcdt it's subtracted out first
before the fit in lsg star s
and said fit it's fitted during the fit
so
a little bit different approaches to uh
the solutions
um the vcdt um uses the approximations
based off of staffers papers and pilots
work and lsd stars based off regulations
um i just want to put a linear square
approach
and of course the cfs distribution into
the s8
so let's so let's focus in on the dc dt
and lsusar
these are very good are talking about
models to look at your data
the biggest problem with these models is
that
um it doesn't have a resolution so
you're not going to get
um uh multiple species
you're going to get a broad peak also
these
uh vcbt and lg star which is um
related to the g-star s are bossy and
fits to the data
so those are i mean you can do a little
bit of trickery with it and get some
you know multiple species as the polymer
guys do um
but um it doesn't you don't have as much
resolution it is great when you have you
know a good
well-behaved system but one of the key
advantages of the dc vt and lsc star
is specifically dcdt if there's no
artificial peaks
that is the beauty so that really helps
you to
eliminate artificial peaks okay
so that's something that i use to really
help me out the lsg star is the same way
now lc star um you you can i mean
there's
advantages in the case that you can use
more scams for the lsd star
at times versus the dc-dt which is a
pairwise approach
um so that's something you have to take
into consideration
now the cfs distribution we know this
we've beaten the dead horse you have
great resolution
with this um this is the i
i i'm now going to say that fda is this
is what they're seeing the ema is what
they're seeing
it's the easiest output to understand
currently
now the 2d spectrum analysis takes the
tf distribution
and brings it to a whole different level
remember i was talking about your f of
zeros in which we're using the average
value for
the save as distribution however for
your 2dsa
you can fit individual species and look
at different
f40s to describe those species
individually
and again that is um a very complicated
analysis but it's
something that you use to really tease
out what is real what's going on your
system if you have an ill-behaved system
i usually plug it into both cfs and the
2d
estate right now the simplest system to
go forward
is the simplest output is the cfsd
solution
if you really want to tackle some of the
more complicated programs you see in
abnormalities
i usually use a combination of all four
of these
to really figure it out and if you want
to really go into this
um there are great workshops by p shook
for the cfs distributions and by boris
glamour for the 2d suv and i highly
recommend
you attend vote to really get an idea of
what these systems are
because there are courses in themselves
thank you like so so
um moving forward can you
explain regularization in the context of
cfs
and compare and contrast the second
derivative technique versus maximum
entropy
okay yeah so i'm going to give my a very
high level overview of uh
of regularization in this case and a
very high level
derivative of max because uh the second
derivative of maximum energy because
we're not going to get into the
equations and we're these are all a
study
in themselves so in terms of
regularization
um what we're looking at it's one of the
approach to solve the integral equations
of said fit and what it does it looks at
um
the probability space for all
distributions again we're considered to
consider all s values um
equal in this case and we want what we
want to do in a second in in a very
global we want to explore the space
apply it um as statistically a
constraint around it that gives you
a accessible fit that best describes the
data
so regularization basically um
does this by giving some parsimonious
distributions
and then applying a constraint to it
that is
slightly worse than the best because you
have again this
this is a course in yourself is because
you have
oscillations in the system so what
happens you want to
not have as much oscillations you take a
step back within your constraint
to give you a slightly worse fit that
still
describes statistically your data and
this is the one the approaches
to solving for the integral equations
the integration and integral equations
to the lamb equation
so that's the very high level
over overview of that now the difference
between
the second derivative and the maximum
entropy
they're both um um
we both select the most parts of uh
persimmons distributions
all right that gives you statistics for
fits
um however the um
the best distributions is the basis of
prime knowledge of the distribution so
um in terms of second derivatives we're
looking at that total curvature
um in your system in terms of um
maximum entropy you're looking at
information informational
entropy so i mean those are um those
okay
it's going to be very different
difficult i'm not very difficult to
explain
one question but the difference is is
that what you're looking
for is the peak shape so let me just
break it up very simply
in maximum entropy you're going to get
very
asymmetrical peaks okay second
derivative will give you very
symmetrical peaks
um both are statistically relevant
and statistically acceptable so they
give you the same kind of the same
approach
so i use second derivative of times
um to help my maximum entropy i mean and
it just it doesn't what your approach is
so
one looks at the total curvature and it
looks an informational entropy
but one gives you more um
statistical um um
sorry um asymmetrical peaks won't give
you so much good peaks
um so what you want to to really um
look at is which one best describes your
data
now switching to um back and forth or
displaying both is probably a good idea
to figure it out um to do it
but there's um better explanations not
better explanations but more
in-depth explanations of the second
derivative the maximum entropy
in um online i said fit
um dot com um analytical health
certification dot com so if you go in
and read that it will give you some of
the the the key differences
that i explained between the two
all right thank you lake because i do
believe that
a lot of users are going to
be benefited by having an operational
understanding of what are best practices
while performing a fitting procedure and
i think you've answered some of those
questions
from that perspective really nicely so
and moving forward again in the context
of cfs
can you talk briefly about the relative
merits
of fitting by either simplex or
simulated annealing
or by levenberg marquardt okay so
this is good because this is part of the
um the algorithms that you're using to
get
your solutions and the simplex and
similar
alien annealing and your living bird
market
are just different approaches to get
your
your solutions so instead fit the
default is your simplex
so these are algorithms that try to get
you
from a local minima to a global mix okay
one of the the key reason one of the key
things
i do is switch back and forth
between my simplex and my levelboard
market
i can do stimulating annealing at times
but as a
computationally it just takes a longer
time
and i'm i'm i'm very impatient so i just
use
basically the simplex than the
martingale so what i would do
is after i fit my data i will switch it
over
to the marquette lambert and do another
fit
and see where those values look at so
i'm looking at my global chi square
i recorded the simulated the simplex
value rmsd i recorded the um
the luvember marquette rmsd i do perform
on both fits then calculate the global
chi-square change
okay that's one of the ways you can look
at it
you're changing this is to make sure
that your data
is in a global minima and doesn't change
as a function of
just switching the algorithms and the
values that you're getting your
distribution that you're getting
are pretty much if you throw the kitchen
sink at it use different
algorithms you're getting the same
answer so usually i switch between back
and forth between
two to arrive at um the answer
now another way i do it is changing it
um some of the
critical parameters for example my web 0
to a non um a non optimal value
and see where it converges back by both
algorithms and then calculating the goal
of the global chi-square
so i would definitely use both
um similarly on the end if you have the
time the computational power go right
ahead and do it because that's just
that's that's that's um exploring
basically a temperature gradient over
time i think you're just changing the
values to that point in time
but as simple as the market if you
switch back and forth computationally is
very easy to do
and it can give you a really good handle
on where your global minima is so i
highly recommend
doing that thank you like
i think uh what i'm getting out of your
q a discussion is a general idea that
uh you're really encouraging the end
user
to play with the options list and see
what happens and
i i find that really nice this
encouragement
so with that we are at the last question
we have
right now in front of us and that is
what confidence level do you use during
fitting and
why okay so
i um so so we think of it you know in
the simplest terms we think of the
f the f ratio as a confidence in
interval
and you can say it's you know 0.68
is two standard deviations and you know
um 2.95 is one standard deviation
right um but it's not only that
um so we got to think about it as the
amount of regularization
that you're using okay so
um when i do my fix the initial thing i
do
is take off all regularization i set
that value to zero
and i fit the data and i see exactly
what the data looks like without any
type of regularization so i know that i
list the number of peaks
i see where they're at and then i say
okay
without any regularization this is what
i get because i don't want biases in my
data
um and i want these picks to be
described well
then i usually go to about 0.68.68 seems
to be a very good sweet spot
in this case um
and that really helps with when you have
peaks that are shoulders that was not
described out
um really well so you're applying a
a certain amount of regulation so 0.68
is
a really good value in the sense that
you get
a good a good description of your data
okay um peaks um
their shoulders you know it helps do the
discrimination
between closely related peaks because
remember
when i'm doing this these types of
analysis i have an eye towards
a cgmp method so i have to make sure
that this data
can when i'm finished with the fitting
can be applied
um the same way in a qc environment
in which i can you know have discrete
species for good integration
okay so i'm always thinking that now
not to say that 0.95 is um
is bad but what you do have in there is
that
it basically it's not smoothing
okay it's a difference between smoothing
regularization
but it looks like the peaks the shoulder
peaks kind of disappear because you have
the two species when you apply a lot of
regularization
start to merge so that shoulder becomes
folded into that
that peak the peak to the right or the
peak to the left
okay so you have to be very careful with
that knowing that you're in your head
that
too closely related species low
concentration that are
not very um um separated can merge
together
and applying the maximum amount of the
of the
regularization will merge those peaks
so you have to this is very key very
critical
when you're looking at the anticapsid
and the heterogeneity
in your partial capsules
and now you have geneticity in your
full capacity so you got to be very
careful you have to be
very careful in how much regularization
you apply
personally i use 0.68 i switch it over
to 0.95 to see
what those changes are again this is a
systematic approach
you have to be able to you know
confidently
say that your fit best describes that
data and
very critical if you're going into a
cgmp method
for validation and as a release test it
can be
done by everyone and is reproducible
okay so i always use i start off with
0.68 switch between 0.95
look at the differences and my final
method
if it's a very good described system
usually
0.68 i will leave it there
thank you like fantastic answer you know
for what it's worth
i'm going to quote a very senior and
highly cited scientist whose name i will
not mention
he had once told me that the biophysics
world is divided into those who use
0.68 and those who use 0.95 as their
preferred confidence levels
and the two groups usually don't talk to
each other
[Laughter]
yes so so
um i'd like to um so we are actually out
of time and
i want to uh thank lake for answering
all of these questions
in such great detail i'd like to remind
our audience
that those questions that we were unable
to answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period
where the presentation will be available
will be answered by
dr paul or by myself via the email
address that you've provided
at the time of registration so thank you
again dr paul
do you have any final comments for our
audience
um make sure that you read
um auc is a very powerful technique
um and it's very critical in the
aav field gene therapy field um
for characterizing not only your
aavs but every type of serotypes
your your lengthy viruses retroviruses
it is the gold standard so i highly
recommend that
you use and use and implement it and
make sure you read it's the easiest way
to
overcome the barrier of learning
to do the analysis
well thank you dr paul before we go i'd
like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
again the questions that we did not have
time to address today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact info
which you've provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank
dr paul for his time today and for his
important research contributions again
we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor beckman
coldstar life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it is available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you
and goodbye